Let's go.
So, auf geht's. Was passiert hier?
Das wüsste ich auch gerne, das frage ich mich jedes Mal.
Irgendeiner dreht seine Katze im Kreis.
So, ich habe übrigens was für einen Keller gekauft.
Es war ein Blutsensor, man weiß ja aktuell mit Überschwemmung nie.
Ich habe einmal den da und dann habe ich noch Zigbee gekauft, weil das irgendwie nur ein Drittel gekostet hat.
Ich hätte es im Keller liegen. Wenn ich Überschwemmung im Keller habe, dann weiß ich Bescheid, dass ich Überschwemmung habe.
Was ich dagegen mache, ist wieder was anderes, aber ich weiß, dass ich dann Überschwemmung habe.
Also ihr wisst, was ich meine.
Die Modansicht hat es nicht gerafft.
Also das Gute ist, dass es piepst sogar und es schickt über SeaWave eine Benachrichtigung an die Heimautomatisierung, wenn es unter Wasser ist.
Ich habe das auch ausprobiert, ich habe einfach einen Teller, so eine Schüssel genommen, Wasser, habe das dann reingehalten, piep, piep, piep, geht.
Automatisch eine Pumpe anschmeißen lassen, ja das ist dann der nächste Schritt.
Das wäre natürlich BigBrain.
Muss man das dann auf einen Schrank drauf machen? Nein, das legt man auf die Erde, das legt man dahin, wo man denkt, dass es nass wird.
Das hat unten Kontakte.
Hier sieht man es, guck mal, das hat unten Kontakte.
Und ich glaube, wenn hier das Wasser dran kommt, dann erkennst du das, dann diese Kontakte.
Doch bei mir hast du eine Abo-Batch.
Abo-Batke, Satke, Bettke.
Es funktioniert, ich habe es auch auf die Erde gestellt, wie gesagt, ich habe einen Schüssel ausprobiert, funktioniert.
Ich bin müde noch, Residenz Leaper, aber ansonsten wie immer.
Übrigens Leute, kennt ihr schon die neueste Verschwörungstheorie?
Ich musste heute morgen richtig kecken, als ich das gelesen habe.
Vielleicht bin ich auch nicht up to date und ihr sagt jetzt, Max, das ist ja schon outdated, das kennt ja schon jeder.
Und zwar, die neueste Verschwörungstheorie, die ich gelesen habe, ist, dass das Hoch, nicht das Unwetter bzw. das Hochwasser,
in Deutschland, dass das durch ein geheimes Wetter-Manipulationsprogramm der USA ausgelöst wurde.
Vielleicht ist das aber auch alt, vielleicht bin ich einfach, vielleicht habe ich es erst jetzt gesehen, vielleicht ist das ja auch schon uralt.
Aber ja, also ich habe einen Comment gelesen unter einem YouTube-Video, wo einer geschrieben hat,
die Leute tun ja immer so, als wäre das offensichtlichste und jeder weiß es schon, nur die Leute wollen es nicht wahrhaben,
hat einer unter das Kommentar geschrieben, dass das ein geheimer Angriff mit dem Wetterprogramm der USA ist, will auch keiner wahrhaben,
hat er reingeschrieben, so nach dem Motto, das ist doch so offensichtlich, dass es das ist.
Ich weiß auch nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist.
Ich weiß auch gar nicht jetzt, ich frage mich eher, was hätte die USA davon, das wollte ich grundsätzlich sagen,
was hätte die USA davon in, ich weiß gar nicht wo das war, Nordrhein-Westfalen, wo waren die ganzen Überschwemmungen,
was hätten die davon, wenn dort ein paar Häuser kaputt gehen, also, ja aber ich weiß nicht wo das ist, wo ist das?
Ich habe keine Ahnung wo das ist. Ja mit Versicherung finde ich ja auch geil, ich habe einen Beitrag gestern oder so gesehen
und da war direkt am Tag, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, das muss man sich mal vorstellen, da war direkt am Tag des Unwetters
die Versicherung da und hat denen, also direkt wo ihr Haus kaputt gegangen ist, war die Versicherung da und hat gemeint,
nee also in Klausel 85 Absatz 2 ist das ausgeschlossen, wozu haben die den Scheiß gekauft, Alter, huge debate,
vor allem das ist sehr feinfühlig am Tag der Überschwemmung direkt dahin zu fahren und zu sagen, übrigens,
Alter, ihr habt gelitten, ja. Ach gibt es diese Verschwörungstheorie auch, dass wir das selbst ausgelöst haben?
Wobei so, sagen wir mal, so weit von der Realität wird das gar nicht so weit weg sein, dass wir das selbst ausgelöst haben,
zumindest indirekt, also wenn man sich mal anguckt, letztendlich sind da wahrscheinlich alle Industriestaaten
der letzten 60 Jahre indirekt mit dran beteiligt, mein klar, du weißt nie, was ohne Klimawandel und sonst was wäre
mit dem Wetterobst, Überschwemmung, keine Ahnung, aber es ist schon nicht allzu weit hergeholt zu sagen,
okay, das ist eines der Extremfälle, die damit was zu tun hat und wer weiß, also indirekt haben wir da sicherlich zum Teil mit beigetragen,
ne, da sind wir ja schon drüber raus, also dass es Klimawandel nicht gibt, sagt glaube ich keiner mehr,
selbst die Hardcore-Verschwörungstheorie-Leute sagen das nicht mehr, mittlerweile ist eher die Frage,
ist es vom Mensch ausgelöst oder nicht und da gibt es ja wirklich äußerst hitzige Diskussionen,
dann hast du welche, die sagen, es ist die Sonne, dann hast du welche, die sagen, klar, es ist CO2,
dann hast du, was habe ich letztens irgendwas gelesen mit, irgendwie der total abgedrehtes Zeug,
der Erdkern wird wärmer oder so Dinger, ach, was auch immer, also, ja, gut, aber ich finde das nachvollziehbar,
also ich finde, auf der einen Seite, natürlich uns betrifft es alle, ja, also ich glaube wir können uns da alle nicht rausrennen,
sagen uns kann das egal sein, aber ich beobachte so Sachen immer gerne, weil eine Sache, die einem da schön dabei auffällt ist,
dass umso einschneidender die Erlebnisse für die Leute sind, also umso einschneidender die Auswirkung für irgendwas ist,
umso unlieber gestehen sich die Leute das ein, dass das passieren wird, man muss sich mal gucken,
muss sich mal anschauen, es wurde ja schon vor 60 Jahren oder wann auch immer das angekündigt,
dass sich das so entwickeln wird, und das hat sich ja auch mehr oder weniger ähnlich, eher sogar noch schlechter entwickelt,
also das war zu sehen, aber das wurde einfach ganz lang ignoriert, und jetzt wird gesagt, ja gut, wir können ja nichts dran ändern,
weil die Aussage, wir können nichts dran ändern, ist natürlich super für jeden Einzelnen, der sagen kann, ja, da muss ich auch nichts machen,
gut, ob wir da jetzt was großartig dran ändern können, das ist tatsächlich eine Frage, da kann man drüber diskutieren,
wir haben ja nun weltweit nicht den allergrößten Einfluss da drauf, aber ich bin mir sicher, früher oder später,
wahrscheinlich eher später, bleibt den China-Chinesen auch nichts anderes übrig, als sich da was auszudenken,
allerdings gehe ich ja davon aus, wir kriegen das überhaupt nicht gebacken, zumindest nicht in nächster Zeit und nicht so,
dass es im Rahmen bleibt, das sind wir einfach zu schwerfällig für, also,
Max habe noch Frage von gestern, wenn man in Debian den App-Config einfach testing steht anstatt den Point-Release, dann hat man recht aktuelle Selenium als Desktop, ja, kann man machen,
das habe ich nicht, ich habe Jam mal Version-Log verwendet, aber das habe ich noch nie probiert mit Abt,
was aber natürlich schon mal gar nicht funktioniert, da muss ich jetzt mal was dazu sagen, ich finde den Ansatz, den wir hier teilweise haben, nicht sinnvoll,
ja wir zerfleischen uns bei so vielen Themen selber, anstatt da ordentlich darüber zu diskutieren, ich will jetzt gar nicht, aber bleiben wir mal bei dieser Klimawandel-Geschichte,
also wir verschwenden sehr viel Zeit darauf, uns selbst gegenseitig zu zerfleischen, anstatt sich mal ordentlich Gedanken drüber zu machen,
und ich habe auch gar kein Problem, wenn man mal Leute zu Wort kommen lässt, die es vielleicht anders sehen,
weil ich finde am besten kannst du Leute, die der Sache skeptisch gegenüberstehen, immer noch überzeugen, indem du ihnen zeigst, ok, das was euch da eigentlich vorschwebt,
ergibt wenig Sinn, und das geht eigentlich nur, wenn du drüber redest und nicht wenn du sagst, nee nee, da mit solchen Leuten reden wir gar nicht,
also du wirst keinen, der irgendwie an irgendwelche Verschwörungstheorien glaubt, jeder von überzeugen, indem du sagst, ihr seid es nicht wert mit euch da drüber zu reden,
das musst du eigentlich anders machen, du musst denn gerade mit den Leuten drüber reden und sagen, hey, das sind die einzigen, vielleicht erreichst du noch ein paar,
die meisten wirst du nicht mehr großartig erreichen können, was wir aber nicht machen können, und da fängt es ja schon an,
also was wir nicht machen können ist, so wie sich das einige vorstellen, dass wir jetzt zurück in die Steinzeit gehen, das wird nicht funktionieren,
und wisst ihr auch warum das nicht funktionieren wird, wenn wir das jetzt machen, also wenn wir jetzt sagen, wir gehen jetzt zurück in die Steinzeit, es wird übertrieben gesagt,
niemand will mitmachen, niemand, warum sollte jemand mitmachen, die sehen bloß, ok, denen ging es mal ganz gut, die sind jetzt zurück in die Steinzeit und denen geht es jetzt schlecht,
meint ihr, das macht irgendjemand nach, die sagen sich, oh fuck, guck mal, die haben es geschafft, in 15 Jahren sich komplett an Arsch zu wirtschaften,
da machen wir, das machen wir doch im Leben nicht nach, man müsste denen eigentlich eher zeigen, guck mal, man kann auch umweltbewusst und mit der nötigen Technik,
die wir dann hätten, wenn wir ein bisschen zukunftsfähig denken würden, man kann trotzdem gut leben und umweltfreundlich sein,
das ist eigentlich das, was man meiner Meinung nach der Welt zeigen müsste, dass man sieht, ok, also das ist das, wo wir als Land, was auch ordentlich Kohle,
also Kohle, Geld meine ich jetzt, theoretisch hat, zeigen müssen, dass man sagen kann, ok, guck mal hier, wir sind in der Lage, umweltfreundlich und mit Wohlstand zu leben,
dann machen das auch andere Länder nach und wenn wir einfach zurück in die Steinzeit gehen, wie sich das an manche Leute gerne vorstellen,
dann wird es keinen interessieren, dann ist eher negativer Fall, dass die Leute sagen oder beziehungsweise andere Länder sagen, nö, machen wir nicht,
warum sollte man das machen, wenn man zugeguckt hat, wie man es verkackt, aber ich bin echt mal gespannt, also ich beobachte das von einer Seitenlinie,
die Diskussionen auf YouTube sind ja da auch richtig, es schlagen ja immer hohe Wellen, aber was wirklich weniger geworden ist,
die letzten 5-6 Jahre über, Leute, die das komplett leugnen, das gibt es eigentlich nicht mehr, vor 5-6 Jahren hat es,
ich habe auf der Arbeit übrigens auch einen Kollegen, habe ich euch ja schon mal erzählt, der war lange Zeit der Meinung, das gibt es nicht,
und jetzt, also es gibt keinen Klimawandel und nix, das ist alles, wobei man sagen muss, der Typ ist nicht blöd,
der hat früher beim Max Planck-Institut gearbeitet und beim, wie heißt das, irgendwo an anderen in Frankfurt,
also der ist wirklich eigentlich relativ big brain, der Typ, der hat die letzten Jahre immer gesagt, ne, gibt es nicht,
mittlerweile ist er aber auch auf dem Standpunkt, dass er sagt, ja, das gibt es, aber das liegt an, keine Ahnung, Sonnenaktivität und sonst was,
meinetwegen, aber wenigstens sind wir jetzt schon so weit, dass eigentlich kaum noch einer sagt, gibt es gar nicht.
Naja, so, aber genug unschöne Dinger.
Äh, ich, ja, ich sehe das übrigens auch, ich würde auch viel lieber Steuern bezahlen, wenn ich sehe, dass die irgendwo ankommen, wo ich,
was, ne, wo ich sehe, dass da was, dass da was passiert und nicht einfach nur in irgendein schwarzes Loch bezahlen,
wo ich keinen platzen Schimmer habe, was damit passiert und eine Sache muss ich jetzt, ich muss einfach noch mal sagen,
man sollte auch nicht im Sinne so von Klimawandel und sonstigen Sachen, man sollte auch nicht alles blind durchwinken,
weil es gibt immer, wenn es solche Katastrophen gibt und Sachen, die sich anbahnen, es gibt immer Leute, die sich bereichern wollen,
an allen Ecken und Enden. Meint ihr denn wirklich, dass alle Automobilkonzern, Chefs über Nacht zu irgendwelchen Umweltengeln geworden sind,
die gesagt haben, äh, ah, ja, äh, meine Kinder haben mich dazu überredet, ich werde jetzt Umweltschützer, also Schwachsinn.
Denen ist aufgefallen, der Scheiß verkauft sich besser, wenn man es grün macht oder wenn man so tut, als ob es grün ist.
Das ist denen doch nicht über Nacht eingefallen. Die haben festgestellt, wenn man grün draufschreibt, dann verkauft sich das besser.
Genauso wie irgendwie ein Hersteller, der Dinger in China oder was weiß ich, Nordkorea oder in Bangladesch mit Kinderarbeit produzieren lässt,
der ist auch nicht über Nacht geläutert und sagt, ach nee, das war doch so eine schlechte Idee, wir geben denen jetzt mehr Geld,
nee, das machen die nur, weil es schlecht ankommt. Es ist einfach, das geht überhaupt nicht darum,
dass die irgendwie jetzt was für den Umweltschutz oder sonst was machen wollen, das ist denen vollkommen egal.
Die stellen das jetzt einfach so hin, wenn ich mir angucke auf Twitter, teilweise Werbung von Shell und Konsorten,
so nach dem Motto, wie viele Bäume sie jetzt gepflanzt haben und sowas, wo ich mir immer denke, was zum Teufel,
warum habt ihr auf einmal so euer Kühe einen Daumen entdeckt? Na gut, klar, weil es gut ankommt, ja, weil es gut ankommt.
Und wir werden sehen, und sehen das ja auch schon, dass im Zuge von Klimawandel und Maßnahmen einfach ganz viele Leute sich versuchen,
da dran zu bereichern, also man sollte nicht alles blind durchwinken und sagen, ja, ja, ist schon gut fürs Klima,
man muss das wirklich hinterfragen und sagen, ist das wirklich sinnvoll oder will da einfach nur einer schnelle Kohle machen?
Und wahrscheinlich kannst du dir im überwiegenden Teil der Fälle das damit beantworten, dass einfach nur jemand Kohle machen will.
Naja, gibt's an vielen Ecken. So, also, was gucken wir uns jetzt an?
So, wartet mal.
Ok, alles klar. Also, ähm, doch, ich finde, ich bin ja auch skeptisch gewesen lange Zeit, ob Elektroautos sowas sinnvolles sind,
ich finde Elektroautos sinnvoll, wobei man halt sagen muss, es ist sicherlich, und das ist wie bei vielen, es ist sicherlich nicht das Allheilmittel.
So nach dem Motto, wir haben jetzt Elektroautos und es gibt keine Umweltprobleme mehr.
Die Hauptfrage bei Elektroautos ist ja nach wie vor, wie werden die Autos hergestellt und vor allem, wie wird der Strom hergestellt für die Autos?
Was Elektroautos aber auf jeden Fall bringt, ist weniger Dreck in der Stadt und das finde ich schon mal ganz gut.
Das habe ich gesehen, das ist tatsächlich, tatsächlich interessant, das können wir echt gucken.
Wobei, wobei, das Video fand ich unterm Strich gar nicht so gut, die haben schon, die haben schon, die haben schon,
die haben schon bessere Videos gemacht, weil im Intro sagen, das können wir uns später mal angucken, im Intro sagen die so nach dem Motto,
es ist einfacher als man denkt und dann zeigen sie zwölf, zwölf Minuten lang, äh, Dinge, wozu wir wahrscheinlich die nächsten 5000 Jahre,
was auch immer niemals im Stande sein werden, aber einfacher als man denkt.
Ja, und eine Sache, die mich auch persönlich nervt, ist, dass wir den zweiten Schritt vor dem ersten erwegen.
Was ich meine, also was ich damit meine, ist folgendes.
Es gibt Diskussionen, ob man nicht Autos generell oder zumindest Verbrennungsautos, was auch immer,
oder wie ich sage jetzt einfach mal, der Einflachheit halber Autos in der Innenstadt verbieten soll.
Die Diskussion habe ich ja überhaupt keine Probleme damit, aber es ist aktuell einfach noch gar nicht möglich.
Das kannst du machen, wenn du beispielsweise Nahverkehr soweit ausgebaut hast oder zumindest mal bei der Bahn Leute hingesetzt hast,
die es persönlich interessiert, dass der Scheiß auch funktioniert.
Wenn du dich darauf verlassen kannst, dass du von A nach B kommst, ohne ein eigenes Auto,
wenn es pünktlich sein muss. Du kommst ja jetzt schon von A nach B, aber du kannst dich halt nicht darauf verlassen, dass es pünktlich ist.
Solange das nicht gegeben ist, wie willst du das machen?
Willst du einfach, dass die Hälfte der Leute morgens nicht mehr auf die Arbeit kommt oder wie?
Wie soll das funktionieren?
So, und wenn du das hinbekommen hast, dann verzichten garantiert ganz viele Leute auf ihr Auto.
Die sagen, hey, mir ist es eh lieber, mit öffentlichen Verkehrsmitteln zu fahren,
wenn es eben eine sinnvolle Alternative ist als mit dem Auto. Ich würde das auch lieber machen, sage ich euch.
Ich mache es ja schon. Ich mache es ja schon, ja.
Aber ich bin auch regelmäßig abgefuckt. Ihr kennt meine Tweets an die Bahn.
Das geht. Ich arbeite in Frankfurt und das geht nicht.
Du hast oft genug Probleme. Das geht höchstens, wenn du direkt in Frankfurt wohnst,
dass du in eine U-Bahn einsteigen kannst, die alle zwei Minuten fährt.
Das funktioniert. Wenn du ein bisschen von außerhalb kommst, was in Frankfurt der riesige, überwiegende Teil der Leute ist,
dann geht das nicht.
Frankfurt ist ja eine Stadt, die hat, was weiß ich, ich sage jetzt mal irgendwas, ich weiß nicht, ob es wirklich stimmt,
die hat keine Ahnung, 900.000 Einwohner in der Nacht und 5 Millionen Einwohner am Tag, jetzt übertrieben gesagt.
Also ein Riesenteil der Leute fährt eben von außen nach Frankfurt bzw. fährt mit der Bahn.
Das funktioniert einfach nicht.
Also wenn du dich wirklich darauf verlassen musst, dann würde ich auch mit dem Auto fahren anstatt mit der Bahn.
So und wenn das so ist, also wenn ich mich da wirklich darauf verlassen könnte, dann hätte ich noch nicht mal mehr ein Auto.
Ich habe das jetzt ja nur notgedrungen für die Fälle, wo ich weiß, ich muss pünktlich sein, aber die Bahn kriegt es nicht gebacken
oder ich komme nicht hin.
Das würde ich machen und ich denke, das würden auch noch viel mehr machen.
Warum sollte man es? Und in der Stadt kommt man mittlerweile auch wunderbar mit Roller und sowas.
Das funktioniert alles, aber jetzt schon über den zweiten Schritt vor dem ersten zu reden, Autos zu verbieten,
bevor der Nahverkehr richtig funktioniert, halte ich für total kontraproduktiv.
Denn man bringt ja damit auch die Leute auf gegen eigentlich sinnvolle Ideen.
Was hast du für ein Auto?
Ich habe das agilste Auto aller Zeiten.
So in grün auch noch.
So ein GG Eats.
Das ist uralt, das ist 20 Jahre alt oder so das Auto ist ja auch 2001.
Also ich habe das keine 20 Jahre, aber das ist 20 Jahre alt.
Ich fahre nicht viel Auto, sonst hätte ich auch schon irgendwas anderes als das Teil.
Die Banger Karre, guck mal, wenn du das tieferlegen willst, das kannst du nicht mal tieferlegen.
Wo willst du das noch hin tieferlegen?
Bei den kleinen Reifen kannst du nichts machen.
Also ich glaube, ich glaube, es geht immer irgendwie.
Aber ich glaube, ich habe noch nie einen getuten Opel Agila gesehen.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das funktioniert.
Ich bin aber auch kein Auto Tuning Mensch.
Fährt sich sehr agil, um ehrlich zu sein, fährt sich das nicht sonderlich agil.
Wenn du sag mal so ab 80 merkst du schon, dass es nicht wackelt,
aber da merkst du den Gegenwind schon, dass das Auto irgendwie komisch ist.
Sonderlich schnell kannst du damit ja auch nicht fahren.
80 fühlt sich an wie 200.
Ja, ist fast so.
Also wenn du damit 120 oder so fährst, du denkst wirklich,
dass du bist in einer Rakete oder so vom Wackeln her oder im Flugzeug, was gleich startet.
Guck mal, hier hat jemand, Big Brain hat gleich jemand nachgeguckt.
Hier in der Kreisend 400.000 Menschen nach Frankfurt machen damit, die zur Pendler Hauptstadt.
Genau, genau.
Und da kannst du nicht einfach sagen, es gibt keine Autos mehr in Innenstädten.
Jeder, der freiwillig mit dem Auto nach Frankfurt fährt, der macht das.
Okay, nicht jeder. Sagen wir mal 95 Prozent.
Es gibt fünf Prozent, die machen das, weil Autofahren geil ist.
Aber die meisten machen das, weil es sonst keine sinnvolle Alternative für sie gibt.
Und Frankfurt ist schon gut angebunden.
Fragt euch erstmal, wo es anders ist.
Und der Rest macht es wie ich, fährt hauptsächlich mit der Bahn,
außer er muss wirklich pünktlich sein, dann fährt er mit dem Auto.
Deswegen kann man jetzt gar nicht sagen, nicht jetzt schon,
so nach dem Motoreihe gibt es nicht mehr.
Du musst erst mal den ersten Schritt vor dem zweiten.
Dann machen da auch viele mit, sicher.
Übrigens, ich muss euch ein Video zeigen, es ist mega lustig.
Wir gucken uns erstmal den... Moment, wo ist der Lockpicking-Lawyer?
Moment.
Hier.
Wir gucken uns erstmal den Lockpicking-Lawyer
und danach gucken wir uns das Verarschungsvideo an, das ist so gut gemacht.
Den kennen wir ja, den gucken wir ja öfters.
Wir wissen jetzt schon, was passiert.
Der nimmt seinen Dietrich, macht dreimal hin und her und das Ding ist auf.
Amazon.
Jeff freut sich.
Okay, das ist... Leute, ihr wisst, ich habe Smart Home technisch vieles am Start und bin da auch immer am Basteln,
aber Smart Locks kommen mir nicht in die Tür, nicht ins Fenster, nicht ins Auto und nirgendwo hin.
Smart Locks, das sehe ich nicht ein.
Es gibt die letzten Jahre so viele Sicherheitsprobleme.
Mein Lieblingsfeature war ja immer noch die Möglichkeit, Leute einzuladen, wenn man nicht daheim ist.
Es gab es ja bei einem Smart Lock, da konntest du Leute einladen, wenn man nicht daheim ist.
Das Problem war plus der Invite-Link, der war so easy selbst zu generieren, dass man sich quasi selbst inviten konnte.
Man musste glaube ich, ich weiß gar nicht, was man...
Man konnte sich selbst inviten, weil der Invite-Link total einfach zu generieren war.
Das heißt, man konnte in fremde Häuser rein damit.
Ein bisschen leise, ja.
Ist das Gesetz Versicherung irgendwo auf der Seite zu Smart Locks?
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Easy, easy.
Ah, klick, klick auf 1, 2 ist binding.
Ah ne, doch nicht.
Easy.
Einfach Wackelchamp machen.
War das immer das gleiche Tor?
Das ist schon zwei Jahre her, da musste man, musste man suchen und wir können auch gleich danach suchen.
Du konntest über die App Invites verschicken.
Und es war möglich, dass du quasi, obwohl du nicht invited wurdest, dir den Invite...
Wahrscheinlich war das immer der gleiche Link oder sowas.
Wahrscheinlich musstest du die ID...
Wir müssen gleich mal suchen.
Wahrscheinlich musstest du die ID wissen.
Das war dann wahrscheinlich einfach nur der Link mit einer ID und deinem Username oder was auch immer.
Ich glaube da gab es, ich glaube da gab es Beheisen Artikel zu.
Gucken wir, gucken wir uns gleich, gucken wir uns gleich an.
Aber jetzt habt ihr den original Lockpicking Lawyer gesehen.
Ihr müsst euch mal die Parodie angucken.
Ich habe mich übelst wegge, weggekackt dabei, als ich das gesehen habe.
Das ist jetzt fake, ne?
Der hatte, der hatte die Sprechweise auch übelst geil drauf.
Der hat das auch noch übelst gut drauf, wie der redet.
Das ist fast wie das Originale.
Der redet wirklich auf die Hand.
Weißt du was das Schlimme ist?
Der originale Lockpick, der könnte das wirklich damit öffnen, wahrscheinlich.
Das ist wie das Original.
Das ist die beste Parodie, die ich in der Richtung hier gesehen habe.
Das ist so nah am Original dran und auch die Sprüche.
Das ist echt gut gemacht.
Das ist so nah am Original dran.
Das ist so nah am Original dran und auch die Sprüche.